come in as we're underway here but in
the interest of time we do want to get
started my name is ann toplovich i'm
director of the tennessee historical
society and it's my privilege today to
introduce edwin black author of an
important new historical work of the
dark history of eugenics in united
states but first i need to give you a
word from our sponsor the southern
festival of books regarding support for
this festival this is an important event
for nashville in the region and we hope
that you enjoy the sessions and other
activities you'll attend this weekend
you'll notice this year that it after at
the end of each session there will be
some students holding a fishbowl for
donations and there will be places
elsewhere in the festival site so we
really hope that you'll consider making
a gift so that the festival may continue
into the future
also please note that mr black will be
going directly to the signing colonnade
in the war memorial building's atrium
after this session and his book will be
available for sale there as well
edwin black began his career in
journalism in chicago and also worked as
a foreign correspondent in jerusalem in
the middle east an award-winning and new
york times best-selling investigative
author his books include ibm and the
holocaust the transfer agreement and a
novel format c
his latest book
war against the week was released early
last month
mr black's enterprise writing has
appeared in numerous newspapers across
the united states and europe and in the
world's leading magazines from playboy
and reform judaism to der spiegel
he is the winner of many awards from his
peers and other groups and he's been
nominated for the pulitzer prize five
times
he has also appeared on tv programs as
diverse as america's most wanted and
oprah
his latest work war against the week
chronicles the story of america's
decades-long campaign to create a white
nordic master race through eugenics
as part of the campaign 60 000 americans
were forcibly sterilized in eugenic
efforts organized by american
philanthropic organizations such as the
carnegie institution and the rockefeller
foundation
in our own mountains of appalachia many
of these sterilizations took place
the program was then transplanted to
germany where the rockefeller foundation
and american eugenicist
founded and funded nazi eugenics to
assemble war against the weak black
headed a team of some 50 researchers
working in dozens of archives in four
countries in accumulating some fifty
thousand documents and i have to say the
documentation in this book is
outstanding
reviews of oregon's the week are
appearing in major u.s newspapers and
magazines right now such as the new york
times usa today esquire and mother jones
reviewers call the book scary and
necessary
fierce and compelling
and what may well be the best book ever
published about the american eugenics
movement ladies and gentlemen edwin
black
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
i'm very happy to come to nashville i'm
very happy to kick off
this festival
and
can everybody here
good
now i'd like to tell you that i'm going
to describe
what is a 600 page book with 1500
footnotes i'm going to
summarize as best i can most of the
information is in the book itself
as i said
i'm happy to be here
but none of you are going to be happy to
hear what i have to say
it's not good news
you're going to get angry
you're going to be shocked
and at the end of my discussion i'll be
happy to answer any questions that you
have
first of all
we are talking about eugenics
now most people are familiar with nazi
eugenics this was hitler's idea for a
master race but very few people
are aware
that the idea
originated not in
nazi germany but in the united states
two to three years before hitler two to
three decades before hitler came to
power
as american eugenicists went on a
campaign to create
a white master nordic race
blonde and blue-eyed
now what are we talking about
we're talking about the idea of eugenics
eugenics itself started
in victorian england
there was a scientist his name was uh
francis galton
the cousin of darwin charles darwin and
this guy galton had these ideas
that
if um
if talented skilled and wealthy people
married other talented skilled and
wealthy people they would have talented
skilled and wealthy children
and he thought by this method
we could improve society
he tried to put a number on this he
tried to find a pattern in this because
he himself of course was a seeker of
patterns he was actually the inventor of
fingerprints
actually god invented fingerprints but
he was the inventor of the method of
identifying and classifying fingerprints
he was the inventor of various fashions
of meteorology and
barometric readings and so he tried to
find a way to quantify the idea of a
good marriage and he came up with this
term from the greek that he invented
eugenics meaning
good life or
or good birth
these ideas were imported into the
united states at the turn of the last
century meaning in the early 1900s
now what was that time like
it was a time of great racial ethnic and
demographic upheaval and conflict what
did we have
we had
millions of jews coming in from the east
uh from eastern europe from russia from
poland we had millions of blacks in the
uh
post-reconstruction and post-civil war
era uh who were be who were being uh
integrated into united states society
indians were being integrated into
united states society millions of asians
had come in from the west as demographic
as indentured
laborers and millions of mexicans were
now uh in u.s territory as as a result
of mexican-american wars in which we
took over a great amount of mexican
terror territory
and there were a bunch of white guys
some scientists some wealthy people
uh men of privileged people
whose names most people don't know names
like charles davenport and harry
laughlin and they wanted it the way it
was
they wanted it the way it was when their
fathers
were running the country and of course
uh
when we say the 20th century we ask
ourselves who is running the 20th
century
the 20th century was being run by guys
from the civil war
just as our 21st century is being run by
guys in the post-vietnam era
and these guys from the post-civil war
period brought all their racist baggage
into the 20th century with them
they considered themselves reformers
they considered themselves liberals
progressives
and utopians
and their idea of a utopia
was a world in which no one would exist
who did not resemble themselves
this all came at a time
when mendel's principles of heredity had
been rediscovered
and proliferated in the united states
now just to refresh you on mendel's
principles of heredity this is where the
peas there's a blemished p and a
and a non-blemished p and the next
generation
some are blemished and some are not
these men
thought that the same principles that
guided peas
guided the development and generations
of human life
and they believed that
poverty
was a genetic trait
criminality chastity morality so in
other words you weren't born into
poverty poverty was born into you
and the best way to get rid of poverty
and improve the world was to get rid of
the people who had this genetic trait as
far as they were con concerned it didn't
matter if you took an african
put them in a white toga taught him to
read latin
and put him in italy that did not make
him a roman that's exactly the type of
language that they used
so it was not the character of your uh
of your family it was not your wealth it
was not your position or your education
what mattered was whether you were of
defective ancestry
racially unacceptable eugenically
unacceptable and whether your progeny
would create more defective individuals
for society and this is what they wanted
to get rid of
they believed
they believed
that
you could breed
a better human being
in the same way that you could breed a
better
herd of cattle a field of wheat
an ear of corn
and consequently
the government agency that put these
guys together was the us department of
agriculture because they wanted to breed
a better species of man also
so these guys
obtained
immense amounts
of corporate philanthropy to back their
ideas
i'm talking here about corporate
philanthropy engaged in ethnic cleansing
the carnegie institution the rockefeller
foundation the harriman railroad fortune
pouring the the the equivalent of
millions into the coffers of these
gentlemen to uh to to establish research
facilities on long island and elsewhere
that would study how best to eliminate
all the defective unwanted unfit and
unacceptable types of human beings
that they considered
eugenically
out of bounds
now what were some of their
methods that they wanted
the first method that they thought about
one of one of the first was gas chambers
public gas chambers now remember we're
talking about the first
20 years of the 20th century and they
thought that the best idea was to march
these guys into public gas chambers uh
in groups uh organized on a township or
a county or a village basis
and uh within a period of time these
guys would disappear but they but they
concluded that our society was not ready
for gas chambers
even still
some individuals
freelanced
for instance there were mental hospitals
in illinois one in particular that i
described in the book in lincoln
illinois who fed their new patients milk
from tubercular cows
and in so doing uh infected
these new patients and then they
allowed them to sleep in open
dormitories
to cross-infect the others and by this
method they would have a 30 to 40
percent death rate of new patients and
tuberculosis of course was uh
in that era
as bad if not worse than aids is today
there were other doctors
who would leave newborn infants who were
defective or deformed
lying without any help or nutrition on
the delivery table one in one in
particular gained national notoriety
he was called the black stork he was
such a hero of the eugenics movement
they actually made a movie about this
guy which you could see at the corner
cinema for 25 cents or sometimes a
nickel
but in the main
they believed that euthanasia would not
achieve what they wanted to achieve
and so instead
they opted for
forced surgical sterilization
and
they got it
they obtained legislation
in 27 states
that forcibly sterilized some 60 000
americans
in addition to forced surgical
sterilization there was marriage
restriction marriage annulment if they
didn't like who you were married they
unmarried you and of course there was
the uh
effort to create concentration camps
which they called farms or colonies for
those who were
feeble-minded so-called feeble-minded or
racially unacceptable they started out
by calling these colonies for the
feeble-minded there were several in
new jersey in massachusetts and uh
eventually they uh uh hundreds of
thousands of individuals were
incarcerated and then forcibly
sterilized
because they were deemed to be unfit
now what kind of people are we talking
about who are unfit we're talking about
southern italians
we're talking about eastern european
jews we're talking about blacks indians
we're talking about asians and we're
talking about white guys with brown hair
they believe that white guys with brown
hair the hillbillies the the hill folk
many of which uh were in these parts of
tennessee
were basically bastardizations and
mongrelizations of the white nordic
ideal
that
they lie that they lionized
in fact the state of virginia published
a booklet entitled mongrel virginians
about these mongrel human beings and
they came up with a number of ideas on
how to
identify these people and one of them
was the alpha test and the beta test it
was a mental measurement test and this
mental measurement test might ask a
southern italian who knew every opera in
aria about a broadway musical he'd come
into ellis island they'd ask him a
question about broadway musicals you
might get a black guy from the farm who
had never been to a big city and they
would ask him something about a
cosmopolitan magazine you might get a a
baptist kid from a rural america who
would of course never smoke that asking
about tobacco ads they would ask people
about tennis records who didn't even
know what tennis was
and by this methodology they were able
to conclude that seventy to eighty
percent of the jews were morons seventy
to eighty percent of the blacks were
morons and these people were worthy of
sterilization
so that they could not perpetuate their
kind this test the alpha and beta test
was ultimately
evolved into something we know today as
the iq test it's just it's the same
basic test but it's evolved
now uh there were so many things that
were upside down about this the
ophthalmologists of america if you can
possibly believe this went on a national
crusade to identify everybody with a
vision problem
find their entire family round them up
put them in concentration camps and
forcibly sterilize them as a way to
improve vision in america
there's a whole chapter about that they
actually took the first step with a with
a bill entered into the new york
legislature although this bill was um uh
defeated
uh uh although these laws were in 27
states there were many people who felt
that this was unconstitutional and so
there was a kind of a go slow approach
and so a fraudulent collusive lawsuit
was created in virginia for the purpose
of making eugenics a test case
the state of virginia wanted to
sterilize the mother the daughter and
the granddaughter of one family it was a
famous case carrie buck her mother and
her daughter so the state of virginia
colluded with the court appointed
attorneys for kerry buck
and
wound a fraudulent appeal right up
through the supreme court and oliver
wendell holmes who was a staunch
eugenicist ruled for the majority
that um
it is better for all the world that's a
quote that these three generations be
sterilized quote three generations of
imbeciles are enough
and in so doing opened the floodgates
and ultimately as i said some sixty
thousand americans were forcibly
sterilized many without even knowing it
some they said we're voluntarily
sterilized i would get some girl from
the hills
uh
of virginia or kentucky or tennessee and
they would ask her
hi honey do you do you like the movies
do you like the cartoons she'd say yeah
i do do you mind if we do something to
help out your health she'd say sure
and they say fine voluntary
sterilization
ultimately
this was not only national policy
enshrined in legislation in 27 states
it became the law of the land
and backing it up
was fake science and fake academics
from the highest corridors of harvard
yale stanford and princeton
it was the greatest of our
universities that provided the sham
signs to back up these races now just so
you understand we are not talking about
a bunch of guys running around a pickup
truck with a confederate flag behind
them in a gun rack in the back window
we're talking about the bite the
brightest and the best the elite
about the greatest
america had to offer and all these laws
were endorsed and debated by 27
legislatures in 27 states this was not
an isolated matter this was not a matter
that never went into in to
implementation it was
a national attempt to engage in ethnic
cleansing and it was supported by
corporate philanthropy
now it wasn't enough
to do this in the united states
these guys the american eugenics
movement
wanted to do this
worldwide
and so the carnegie institution began to
uh sponsor pseudoscientific uh medical
journals
international congresses and research
fellowships uh around the world
especially in europe to proliferate our
ideas into other countries
and we did this successfully spans
getting cohorts of american eu eugenics
to sponsor legislation in canada in
belgium in scandinavia and a particular
pet project of the american eugenics
movement was germany
and they successfully uh
transplanted american ideas of eugenics
into
into germany into the 20s and ultimately
the 30s
and in the and in the 20s it came to the
attention of a guy called adolf hitler
and adolf hitler studied american
eugenics american eugenic laws and
american eugenic theories
and he
conceded openly that he admired him
he admired them
and
he took his pre-existing racism his
pre-existing anti-semitism
and wrapped it
in the idea of eugenics to scientize and
medicalize
his theories
and then switch the word nordic race
with aryan race
to create
the nazi quest for the master race
and he even acknowledged in fan mail to
american eugenesis such as one to
a madison grant
america's chief racist from the american
museum of natural history when he said
your book is my bible
and so
i've been writing about the holocaust
for 35 years
and i finally understood
what nazism and the holocaust was about
i've always said you can document it but
you'll never explain it but if we listen
to the words of hitler and his inner
circle in a common phrase that they used
he said
national
national socialism
is nothing but applied biology
and so
it seems that even
more
than
a war of territorial conquest and
economic plunder
this was a eugenic war a biological war
backed up by a genocidal military in
fact the rockefeller foundation
spent millions to build eugenic
institutions from the ground up
and one of the institutions that they
were building from the ground up
was controlled by a guy called atmar
freihar for sure
and for sure we might say was the chief
nazi eugenicist
and vesher received grants from
rockefeller
and for sure had an interest in twins
in fact twin research was the holy grail
of research
for the eugenics movement
because with twins
you could unlock the mysteries of
defective reproduction
and with twins
you could reveal
the secret
of multiplication of the master race
and for sure
had an assistant
and the assistant's name was joseph
mengele
and for sure
sent mengela
into auschwitz
to finish the program
originally started and funded by
rockefeller
and so millions
of jews and gypsies and other europe
europeans were unloaded
auschwitz
amongst terror and noise
and the one word that each they each
heard twice
was the word twins we want twins
and these twins were gathered
and horrible experiments were done on on
them horrible
they were fused together their veins
were tied together their eyeballs were
were experimented with they were given
terrible viruses pain painful injections
in in the eyes
and we have spent a half a century
trying to understand the unfathomable
nightmare experiments of joseph mengele
but every american eugenicist understood
what a mengele would do
because every day mengele worked
on his scientific reports his clinical
autopsies and dispatched them
two or three times each week to his boss
for sure
in fact
after the holocaust for sure
was actually welcomed back into the fold
of scientific fellowship by his
colleagues in calif in california
now after the holocaust
at nuremberg
eugenics was deemed to be an act of
genocide
a crime against humanity
and the americans
went underground
and the germans on trial
quoted the words of oliver wendell
holmes in their own defense
they entered the california statutes in
california at all times
was
the state where one-half to one-third of
all sterilizations took place
and they were found guilty
and then the americans
changed the name of american eugenics
to human genetics
same guys
same buildings
same film
philanthropic funds
same laboratories
and over
the the span of one or two
generations
this science of human genetics has
evolved into the modern science of human
engineering that we know today which is
peopled by
um
by a
sensitive scientists who are trying to
improve mankind and fight disease and we
certainly welcome and invite every
genetic miracle that we can have
but now
there's a resurgence
of the same
impulse
that caused eugenics in the first place
i'm speaking of new genix
and this time
it will not be
racial dogma and national flags this
time it will be globalization
profit
bottom line
corporate
activity that determines who is fit and
who is not fit to continue their
existence
i give you an example
of
burlington northern santa fe
engaging in secret testing of the dna of
its employees for the purpose of
identifying whoever who has a
predisposition to carpal tunnel
the largest employer and this was just
to avoid work workman's compensation
the largest employer in canada
cancelling the death benefits in an
automobile accident of a man of a
certain ethnic background they tracked
his background and they realized he's
from a group of people who have a
ancestral and hereditary blood disease
and they said well he wasn't qualified
for insurance in the first place
and so now there's a new move to exclude
and to serve
and and
and to surcharge individuals for
insurance
to underemploy them to not employ them
real estate
if you can't get insured and you can't
get a job then you can't get real estate
and legislators are seeing this as the
new threat of discrimination in the 21st
century an anti-genetic
legislation
is already
embraced
by nations all over the world
and this legislation is in our congress
now shortly after i speak
the first vote is going to take place in
the senate to adopt anti-genetic
discrimination laws
to stop gene lining we all remember what
redlining was
now it will be gene
lining and so as we go into the dazzling
21st century
of genetic genies
we hope
that as many miracles as possible come
our way but we also ask
that wall street
and these corporations
and our society look over their shoulder
and make sure that genetics
does not return
from ones it came thank you
and and now i'll uh take questions
if you can stand up and ask your
question loudly we'd appreciate it and
also i would ask that uh
because we have limited time no uh no
speeches or commentaries although many
of you may be outraged and i'll just try
to answer as many questions as possible
who has the first question
uh it's quite frequent that people get
uh are just stunned by this information
because there's so much there people are
quite angry does anybody have a question
okay then i'll use my time to give you
more more more information a lot of a
lot of people ask whether ibm was
involved in this because of course i did
my last book with ibm and the holocaust
and i can tell you that
ibm was not involved in american
eugenics
um that's one of the reasons american
eugenics did not succeed
uh at the level it sought to
to succeed
um uh these uh family tracings and uh
and ancestral records uh were
accumulated on long island and else and
elsewhere on index cards and plain paper
forms
and as a result of that um
there were so many uh millions of forms
and cards that by the time the punch
cards came into uh greater use in about
1920s uh there were too many to punch in
and so eugenics in in america never
achieved the ability to database to
cross
reference all the individuals because
eugenics remember wanted to do more than
get rid of the individual
they wanted the entire family and that
was the key and they could never track
the family as they wanted to simply
because they lacked the database and
capabilities that ibm could could give
them
by the same
token
that's exactly why nazi eugenics worked
in nazi germany because ibm went in
there from the beginning and or it
offered to organize the holocaust from
the identification to the uh exclusion
to the confiscation to the ghettoization
to the to the to the deportation to the
extermination of the jews they organized
it in terms of databasing in terms of
of systematic uh
file keeping record keeping and that's
why eugenics worked in nazi germany now
it's interesting
that when i wrote ibm in the holocaust i
thought
that um the
famous ss race card that ibm developed
for hitler's ss was uh born in uh nazi
germany actually the prototype of this
card was developed originally by ibm new
york for the carnegie institution of
washington in 1928 a half decade before
hitler came to to power as part of the
1928 jamaica race crossing project as
the first step along the way to wiping
out the existence of all black people on
earth
we should also understand
that uh while
most jewish people and my parents in the
jewish community my parents who went
through it know that in the ghettos of
europe uh in the 40s there would be what
they called an accion
that means an action the nazis would
want uh 10 or 20 or 30 or 40 jews to uh
to kill or to work or to to experiment
on and they would just see someone
crossing the street and they would grab
them well 10 to 20 years before this was
going on they were doing this in
virginia with white people
uh they were uh in the back roads of the
foothills uh the uh county wagon would
uh
cruise up and down they would see a
hillbilly just um laying by the side of
the road or maybe a fishing or having
lunch they would grab him
they would uh deem that he was um
genetically or or eugenically unfit
they would find out where his cabin was
back in the hills and hollers
get the entire family maybe 10 or 12
people commit them all to the
institution for the feeble-minded and
forcibly sterilized them all
and
this is of course was officially
sanctioned by the state of red by the
state of virginia
before i go on with more
oppressive shocking information does
anybody have an additional question
okay
let's go on further i'm glad i'm having
the opportunity to give you the
information margaret sanger was a famous
eugenicist you have to understand this
was not just a movement of
of a couple of weird guys this was
entrenched national policy and this was
embraced and advocated by the by the uh
power structure in the united states
all the presidents of of the united
states theodore roosevelt uh woodrow
wilson uh fdr
harding
and
in the case of margaret sanger there's
of course a huge
controversy as to whether she is a
racist or not a racist or anything of
that nature and the documentation shows
that margaret sanger was not a racist
but she was a bigot
she was not a nazi or any kind of a jew
hater but she surrounded herself with
the greatest nazis and jew
haters in the united states people so
virulent
they um
they got fan mail from adolf hitler
and she did want to save humanity
but only the top 30 percent
and so terms like human waste and human
weeds populated her speeches and her
publications
uh as she tried to relieve the teeming
masses by ensuring that
they stopped teaming
now how did i get all this information
well i i deployed about uh 50 volume
volunteer and other researchers
into some 110 archives and libraries in
four countries generating some fifty
thousand documents as has been said and
everything was done on a primary basis
we didn't trust uh any of the materials
that we have uh found printed on the ma
on the subject of you of eugenics we
have found that almost everything on the
internet
about eugenics is either
all wrong half wrong or partially wrong
and it's very important for me to make
sure that my information is bulletproof
and so um
we of course have one footnote folder
but behind every footnote there are some
1500 in the book 100 pages of footnotes
and within 30 seconds we can pull out
the written documentation original
documentation on virtually every
footnote and it's important to
understand that many of the individuals
who have written about this have done
pioneering work
but there are errors
and we have hopefully corrected those
errors for
for the few uh for the future my book
only begins the sad saga of
investigation of eugenics i've taken you
to this um to this dark frightening
house of horrors
but
about half the information that i found
was never used why because eugenics
which was an international movement and
a national policy was implemented on
intensely local basis and so i could
have written 50 books
and actually that would have only been
the start and so now we need many many
more investigative journalists uh to
explore the attics and the closets and
the basements and the dark corners of
this terrible house of eugenics to
discover the additional stories and
maybe after
20 30 or 40 books will we begin to
understand just the dimensions
of this problem now here's a question
i've read about the first 75 pages of
your book i'm in the process of reading
it now were there any well-known figures
at the time
alarm bells went off for them and they
were speaking out against this movement
was was there anyone we could point to
who said you know this is really bad
thing something terrible is going to
happen that's good that's it
that's a good question uh she wants to
know if anybody who was prominent or
otherwise uh uh spoke out against this
at the time and the answer is plenty of
people
the majority of americans this became
public knowledge of course because there
were public laws passed starting from
190 uh 1907
in 1909 this became public knowledge and
the polish people jews italians blacks
and
spanish people they didn't want to see
themselves wiped out they thought this
was all wacko that this was nuts
they couldn't believe that anyone was
doing this and so there's a great deal
of public ridicule in the newspapers
among the investigative reporters and
consequently these men persevered in the
face of public ridicule
so even as
people are declaring that this is sham
science it's leaps of logic these people
are just inventing more and more phony
data
and phony signs to support their racist
ideas and what's interesting is that in
1938
as late as 38
when hitler is pushing jews across the
borders of europe to create a refugee
crisis the governor of the state of
connecticut
secretly hires one of these carnegie
institution
experts
to conduct a eugenics survey of
connecticut and to determine who can
stay and who cannot stay based upon
their racial uh profile their health
their uh mental well-being and they
their plan was to uh score everybody
racially and ethnically and genetically
and eugenically and then to simply expel
the ones they didn't like to their
ancestral homes in kentucky
massachusetts new york
or uh
perhaps tennessee
and in so doing create domestic refugees
so uh it isn't that people didn't object
it's that these were the men who had a
grasp
on the halls of power sometimes just one
man would go on a personal crusade to
lobby an entire legislature and uh
enable legislation to persecute and uh
um and discriminate against so many
different types of people you know this
is what it's important to understand
that if you're willing to get rid of one
ethnic group
one minority you're willing to get rid
of them all and that is why i'm
delighted that this book has resonated
not only with jews but with blacks with
hispanics with
with asia with asians and all people
who have an understanding that once one
man
sets himself up as the biological
tribunal as to who can live and who
cannot live
we are facing a potential for genocide
is there another question this gentleman
here
how relative do you think this uh
this is in today's world especially with
the
evolution of
of our social society
how uh rel how relevant yes how relevant
is this to to today
very relevant we don't have eugenics as
we had it
then we don't have that today although
there is that entrenched minority in the
aryan brotherhood and in the and in the
white racist community that want to
practice the identical same eugenics
they have hooped this to their chest as
a as a crusading banner but there is of
course
um this whole privatized notion of human
life and this has got to stop
um uh there's an 18-month uh
uh secrecy protection for patents human
life is being patented it's subject to
ndas
and so we're going to find out after
it's been done now what's interesting
is that all this genetic information is
being sold to the highest bidder and the
company that's been established to uh
purvey this information worldwide is a
company called ibm life sciences nordic
the same people who organized the
holocaust for adolf hitler and so what
we need is to remove the secrecy remove
the ndas
and say if you're experimenting in human
life
it's public
there's nothing private about it you
cannot brand human life and remember
the abuses that we fear
which took 30 years to transmogrify
from
wacko ideas in long i
island to genocide in auschwitz
that was at a time when there were no
pdas no fax machines no internet
these ideas that we have today could
transmogrify a lot faster and so what we
what we want to avoid
is that the uh the genie of genetics
be used to persecute
or to conduct a new war against the weak
it should only be used to help all signs
should only be used to help not to
obliterate another group of people i
hope that answers your question
is there another question anybody else
all right how much more time do i have
because i can talk forever
all right yes
during world war ii when fdr refused to
bomb concentration camps or even bomb
the railroads taking people to them um
would he have known personally of the
american connection
or uh would that have kept him from from
taking any really great strides to to do
away with the case that's a good
question
and what about the american first
committees would they have been
influential
yes of course uh the question was uh fdr
refused to bomb the uh death camps in
nazi germany of course he did
bomb right next door to the
rubber factory
and
is it
was there any did he have an
understanding of this eugenics fdr was a
backer of eugenics he in fact when he
was governor of new york referred
international inquiries about the worth
and value of eugenics to some of the
chief nazi uh
nazi uh
uh proponents in california such as paul
popeno
and
but as to whether the uh camps were
bombed or not for eugenic reasons i do
not believe that there is a really good
tie-in there what i will say if there is
a concept we in the jewish community
know of called paper walls why couldn't
the jews get visas to come into the
united states during the 30s many people
have speculated that fdr was
was
anti-semitic or it was too
bureaucratic or there was politics
all these different notions but we now
know from the book we have now revealed
that
the tenor of the times was expressed
biologically
in a
secret network of eugenic stations and
eugenic protocols set up throughout the
consulates of europe by the carnegie
institution
as a part of its involvement with the
1924 national origins act and so
everyone who came into the united states
had to pass by a
a a eugenic standard
and it was the carnegie institution that
laid down the principle
that
jews are a
jews are a race not a religion which was
echoed 11 years later by adolf hitler
very knowingly and tellingly in the
nuremberg laws of 1935.
another question from someone
all right somebody asked me who helped
and who hindered
you want to know who helped my research
and who tried to obstruct me you do okay
they all helped
rockefeller foundation carnegie
institution planned parenthood all the
organizations and many small museums in
tennessee in appalachia uh all helped my
research above and beyond the only one
who refused to help my research was of
course ibm which refused to allow me
access to its archives
and these organizations
should by no means be judged today by
what their
they were involved in uh 50 80 and 90
years ago
uh that
even then they were involved in much
much more than eugenics and uh we should
be aware that these uh organizations uh
are regretful of their past
um before i uh carry on another does
anyone else have a question go ahead
again
ibm
life sciences nordic
what is that and
why are they being mentioned
ibm life sciences nordic is
pre-positioned to get all the national
dna
data banks and other genetic information
and purvey it to the highest bidder
and they're managing it
and i'm sure that these people are uh
that the people who make up this company
uh are dedicated a decent scientist as
uh
all the people of ibm are today but uh i
do know that ibm operates in secrecy
that ibm operates
for the bottom line that ibm obscures
what it's really doing and so since we
are talking about human human life
and since we are talking about human
engineering i believe that the same
request i made of all of genetics
applied to ibm and to any other company
that wants to trade in human material
and that is take away the secrecy tell
us what you're doing who you're selling
it to uh what the and what the uh per
what what the purpose is i think it's
interesting that they should uh um uh
call the name of this company ibm life
sciences nordic another question
we're done thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
and i it's a fascinating reading and i
recommend it to all of you so thank you
mr black thank you
and author edwin black is just one over
200 authors appearing this weekend at
the southern festival of books in
nashville
as we head outside to look at the